i
looked into trump and i found that he
had um
one of the people close to him was this
guy called felix sater a russian-born
gangster
who back in the day in wall street in
the 90s and fallen out with a fellow
broker
and it smashed a margarita glass
and then put the stem of the of the of
the glass
into this guy's neck giving him 110
stitches
and the guy goes inside when he's inside
then he teams up with the gambinos for a
pump and dump scam worth 40 million
dollars
pumping up a share price which is [ __ ]
and then they
they pull other suckers come in then
they pull out
then then he does something um
soviet union falls and he ends up
doing uh this is felix sata he ends up
working i think for the agency
buying stinger missiles from the
um in afghanistan
using cutouts or whatever he does
something
which means that they um um they let him
out
earlier and then he ends up in the trump
organization
but this guy is a gangster thick with
organized crime
that the the cia might have used him
uh to do some skullduggery on their
behalf that's
good on him it doesn't make him an
honest or reliable business partner
at all and i hit trump with that why
didn't you say to felix sater
who has got a trump card a trump
organization card felix sata
and the trump organization email address
of memory serves
why didn't you say the felix sata you're
connected with the mafia
you're fired this is on youtube
and trump says john
maybe you're thick but in the united
states we have a contract
and you can't break the contract now
actually down the track i did a film for
bbc news night
this is on youtube and it's called trump
and the mob or trump and his links
with the mob in which i find a clause
in the contract he'd signed with felix
sater
um um or the the business entity he was
engaged with
and um satan was part of it which is
called the bad boy clause that if
sata had been a bad boy then he'd have
to cough that up and it
it was his responsibility to cough so
there was perfectly good
legal contractual reasons for trump to
do that
trump called me thick what does that
mean thick
a thick means stupid okay maybe you're
thick john said trump to me
all of my colleagues on panorama love
this moment and so whenever we go for a
beer
they always you know there's always some
[ __ ] point where somebody says well
maybe you're thick
john and you can watch
and i don't i don't
i don't say anything but you can tell
from my face
that i don't like it because you know i
wear glasses
i've written 12 books
i'm clever um i mean i don't have to
like
i you know i went to the london school
of economics i'm not that clever
but i'm not fake anyway never mind but
the point is that trump has worked out
perfectly how to hit me
um but i um this isn't my first rodeo
and i roll with it and then i
say um but i press him on it and then
trump says listen i've got to go to a
meeting
he's made it up there isn't a meeting
he's just getting out because he doesn't
like me
and he comes over to to hold to shake my
hand
and i put my hand up like this and i say
one last question why did you buy your
concrete from fat tony salerno
that tony was the gambino
and the genovese crime families man in
manhattan
and if you bought concrete back in the
day
you bought it from fat tony or else you
would have trouble with the mob
and trump's building is entirely
concrete
he bought his concrete from fat tony he
the evidence suggests shares a lawyer
roy cohn um with fact tony that tony was
in the mob
there was a wonderful uh great reporter
for village foyer school wayne barrett
who i met
in 2016 in the spring
and uh wayne had um had always been on
trump's case back in the 80s
fantastic guy and i asked wayne and this
is in the video
um trump and his links from the mob it's
on youtube
and i asked him wayne
about fat tony and wayne said
fat tony fattoni was fat
okay it's a great piece of telly
honestly it's lovely
wayne told me this story which is yucky
but i'm going to tell it
to you um because
uh why not um
wayne found out that trump was uh
you know one of his casinos got blown up
the other day
this video with the trump casino on
youtube
on on twitter being blown up
um how did i miss this okay anyway
um which casino one of the trump
casinos in atlantic city okay maybe by
the way
um i've watched it i didn't watch it
closely
the day could be wrong but never mind
they've had to somebody in
it looked like recently but it could
have been a couple of years back have
blown up a trump casino
because it was abandoned and lost money
when one of his casinos was opened wayne
had been
running stories about trump getting in
bed with the new jersey mafia
who owned the land so that trump
effectively had to get uh to pay off the
new jersey
mafia to start this casino and then
in those days the new jersey mafia based
in philly
was more murderous than the new york
mafia
in the 80s common ground so
wearing this reporting that trump's
getting in bed with some very nasty
people indeed
big dirty killers organized crime
trump hates this hates it and
wayne barrett is on his hate list
wayne is not invited to the
um the launch of the casino
wayne hires a young researcher called
tim o'brien
who has ended up working for bloomberg
and working
for joe um for joe biden and also being
a great reporter
i for i think um the wash post for a bit
or whatever
anyway tim o'brien as wayne's assistant
at this point he's like he's
22-23 just out of college
he's on the inside and between them they
work it out and basically
um tim o'brien goes to a door
and lets um wayne in the back way
so he can get into um the um
this party there's trump all his women
and the moment you know trump sees wayne
wayne is arrested by trump security
who are atlantic city police officers
working moonlighting for the trump
organization
they lock him up and because of the
trespass
basically they can lock him up for the
night and they have to let him go in the
morning
that night wayne tells me in 2016 when
he's dying of cancer
he spends the entire night handcuffed
chained to a radiator and there's
another prisoner
in the cell which is a police holding
cell not a
okay and the other guy is mentally ill
and spends the entire night
masturbating trump
would have known that because
it's he owns the atlantic city police
department
that's when barrett's allegation or
concern denied any wrongdoing
so what trump is doing is he's
deliberately getting
to wayne by organizing this or rather
the cops would have known this nutter
and would have told trump about
it to make trump enjoy that moment to
sadism
and when i read mary trump his aunt's
book about donald trump
um or his is mary trump
um mary trump
is trump's niece that's right but he's a
psychologist
but she's fallen out with him because
trump was
horribly cruel to her father fred trump
jr
this married completely with the story
that wayne told me
but there was something brutal and nasty
and disgusting